A lot of functions can look really ugly, and
be hard to work with.
On the other hand there are some lovely functions
that have wonderful properties.
What's amazing though is that some of these
beautiful functions that can approximate many
other functions, even ones that look very
bad.
Today we'll look at one example of this kind
of thing: the Fourier series.
Ok let's start by considering all the functions
you can draw on a line between --L to L. So
what do our nice functions look like?
We can make them like this:
First draw a dot at 0, and dots at the end
points.
Now connect them like this.
You might recognize this as this sin function.
Then for the next one, put down the original
dots and now one in between each of them,
and a swiggle to connect them.
This is also a sin function.
Keep repeating the process, and now we've
made an infinite number of nice functions-
but wait, let's make more: take all of our
previous ones and shift them over so that
their first peak is now in the middle.
These are all cos functions.
Now we finally have all the nice functions
we're going to work with.
You might be wondering what exactly is so
nice about these functions.
I won't say too much about that here, besides
noting that they're periodic and infinitely
differentiable.
Instead, I'll put some links in the description
about their usefulness, and in the next next
video I'll explain why they're super important
in quantum mechanics.
Ok so back to our functions, there are an
infinite number of them, but it's obvious
that they are only a tiny fraction of all
possible functions.
It only starts to get interesting we start
combining them in a special way called a linear
combination.
This is how you make a linear combination.
Pick some of the nice functions.
Now multiply each of these functions by a
number.
This has the effect of stretching or compressing
each of them.
Then add these functions together.
For the rest of this video, we're only going
to consider combining the functions in this
way.
We won't, for example, think about multiplying
functions.
Anyway, as you can see from this example,
the resulting function isn't one of our nice
ones.
That begs the question, exactly want kind
of functions can you make using these linear
combinations?
The amazing result, know as the fourier series,
says that actually, you can make a lot of
different functions this way.
Let's see an example to see how this works.
Let's use the function x cubed.
On the interval -Pi to Pi, x cubed looks like
this.
We're going to try and approximate it using
our nice functions.
The fourier series tells us what coefficients
to use in our linear combination.
We start out by plotting the first approximation
to it using the squiggles with the biggest
wavelength.
That looks really really bad.
That's ok; we'll go onto linear combinations
of two of our functions.
Better, I guess...
Let's do a few more.
This is the 3rd order approximation.
As we get toward the twentieth approximation,
it actually looks pretty good!
Ok, so our swiggly functions can approximate
smooth curved function like x^3 really well.
Let's give it more of a challenge with a function
that isn't even continuous.
You see, by the twentieth approximation, this
looks pretty good.
In fact, we can prove that as we go to higher
and higher orders, we can make this approximation
as good as we want.
Here are some more examples and you can see
in each case that the approximation works
well for them too.
The last one is actually a fractal, one of
the nastiest types of functions there are,
and yet the Fourier Series still can approximate
it.
I find this completely mind-boggling.
Why should a bunch of squiggly lines give
a good approximation to functions that look
nothing like them?
I have no idea.
What's even cooler is that this version of
the Fourier series is merely a special case
of an even more powerful one.
Suppose you have a complex valued function
on the interval from negative L to L. By that
I mean a function that only takes real numbers
between negative L and L as inputs but returns
complex numbers.
The general version of the Fourier series
can even approximate those kind of functions.
Here's how.
First we need a new set of nice functions,
because our old ones are real valued and that
won't do for this.
This is how we create the new ones:
To make the first one, take the two biggest
squiggling functions multiply one by the imaginary
number i, and add them together.
You might recognize this as a complex exponential
function.
Do the same thing with the next two, and you
see this is another exponential with a smaller
wavelength.
And of course, we just repeat this process
forever to get the rest.
So these are our new nice functions.
To approximate a function -real or otherwise,
with them, we do exactly the same thing as
before, we take linear combinations.
This version of the Fourier series will tell
us what coefficients to use.
For real valued functions, the approximation
is exactly the same as if we did it with our
original fourier series.
Here's one example of a complex function being
approximated.
So that's what the Fourier series is about,
approximating functions.
However, we only talked about how to approximate
functions on a certain interval.
How to we do it if we want to approximate
a function on the entire real line?
That's where the Fourier transform comes in.
If you want to know about that then I'll see
you in the next video.